we're going to turn out of the turmoil
from the failure of two major Banks
customers lined up yesterday outside the
headquarters of Silicon Valley Bank in
Santa Clara California hoping to get
their money back and earlier trading was
temporarily halted for more than a dozen
other Regional Banks as their stock took
a hit that's despite Federal action
designed to calm the markets Errol
Barnett is outside the headquarters of
Silicon Valley bank once again for us
that bank being sued Now by shareholders
investors who have been wiped out Errol
good morning
Tony good morning to you and that
lawsuit now class action lawsuit being
built by shareholders is just one of the
fresh headlines the Federal Reserve
board also reviewing its oversight of
this institution and the customers I
spoke with all lined up yesterday yes
they're relieved they're now getting
some access to their money but they are
deeply frustrated that any of this
happened in the first place
are you satisfied with the service you
received today and what the FDIC is
telling you happens next
sort of it was a somber morning there is
a lot of volume there's a lot of people
asking their money as representatives
from the Federal Deposit Insurance
Corporation or FDIC greeted customers of
Silicon Valley bank waiting outside
headquarters for hours just for a chance
to withdraw their deposits you can
either do it with the cashier's check
cash or wire and you have to be pre-set
up to do the wire so it left the cash
and cashiers checked and who wants to
carry out a bag full of money out into
their car Bob B opened a personal
account with svb around two decades ago
at risk most of his life savings the
officers of the company causes a bank to
crash like they did here and people are
losing money they should go to jail
similar scenes took place at Signature
Bank in New York which dealt heavily in
cryptocurrency and failed just two days
after svb I cannot believe it despite
the government's intervention the
volatility during Monday's trading
proved investors are still nervous about
contagion in fact trading halted for at
least 20 other Regional Banks after
steep drops First Republic was down more
than 60 percent meanwhile CBS News has
learned svb was operating without a
chief risk officer for months before one
was hired in January President Biden
said those responsible for the collapse
of these banks will be held accountable
I'm going to ask Congress and the
banking Regulators to strengthen the
rules for banks and repeated that none
of the losses would be paid for by
taxpayers instead the money will come
from the fees that Banks pay into the
deposit Insurance Fund
now Federal officials say they plan to
auction off what's left of svb as far as
its assets and that class action lawsuit
we reference claims that those who led
this company concealed how raising
interest interest rates left the banker
susceptible to liquidity issues Tony
all right Earl thank you very much